have you gone down the road of making
huge changes to your eating habits only
to find yourself failing over and over
again well the truth is making huge
changes and expecting quick results
isn't manageable and it may only work
short-term what we want to focus on is
to learn to make small manageable and
sustainable changes that will have a
huge impact long-term so I want to share
with you 15 really simple food swaps to
help you slash the calories without
making huge sacrifices to your favorite
food and flavors granola may sound like
a healthy breakfast option it might
shock you to know that just half a cup
of granola has about 300 calories it is
high in oil butter and sugar
so before muesli instead Loosli has the
same raw ingredients as granola but
without any oil butter or added sugar
you'll be saving about 156 calories a
chav ants latte with whole milk has an
average of 200 calories that's 10
percent of your daily calorie
recommendation shopping for a cup of
americano and you'll be saving 200
calories if it's too strong to your
liking you can always add a little bit
of semi skimmed milk Oh so before a cup
of green tea 1 tablespoon of mayo has a
whopping 90 4 calories and 10 grams of
fat it is high in calories but very low
in nutrients so before Greek yogurt
instead 1 tablespoon has 14 calories and
under 1 gram of fat you'll be saving 80
calories use it as salad dressing or
dips mix it with tuna eggs chicken a
potato or use it as the base of a creamy
dessert the dressing you choose may ruin
a healthy salad 1 tablespoon of creamy
salad dressing has a whopping 70
calories it's loaded with saturated fat
sugar and salt keep your salad healthy
and stop for oil and vinegar based
dressings instead you'll be saving 55
calories plus you'll be adding healthy
fats into your meal 1 small packet of
crisps has 170 calories and close to
zero nutrients they are
is saturated fats calories and salt so
pay for plain or lightly seasoned
air-popped popcorn one cup only has 31
calories it is packed with antioxidants
fiber and excellent for digestion don't
be fooled by soups one cup of creamy
mushroom soup can rack as many as 220
calories and 17 grams of fat shopping
for homemade broth base soup which is
just 18 calories per cup you'll be
saving more than 200 calories and also
your waist line a cup of whole dairy
milk has 148 calories stop before
unsweetened almond milk and save 88
calories almond milk is also great for
vegans of those with lactose intolerance
swap soda drinks including a diet soda
for sparkling water you will still get
the face of a can of soda but with other
chemicals colorings or artificial
sweeteners that can lead to weight gain
plus you get to meet your daily
requirement of drinking at least 2
liters of water 1 milli packet has about
416 calories if you want to reduce your
cup intake so before to medium sliced
breads you'll be saving about 236
calories or stop it for one medium
tortilla wrap and save 276 calories if
you want to go for a lower cup swap and
increase your vegetable intake then swap
the tortilla wrap for lettuce wrap
lettuce is also known as free food
because it's extremely low in calories
and you can read in abundance to fill
you up without piling on weight dried
fruits are high in nutrients and make
excellent healthy snack however if
you're watching your weight and want
more volume shopping for fresh fruits
instead a serving of fresh fruit offers
more volume and contains more water
which will keep your food quicker and
longer sugar is one of the top causes of
obesity across the world one teaspoon of
sugar contains 15 calories and no other
nutrients it is also very addictive
shopping for stevia stevia is a natural
sweetener and does not contain any
calories it is 300 times sweeter than
sugar
han-soo you only need a very small
amount to replace sugar it is also a
great sweet alternative for the
with diabetes a three and a half ounce
of dairy ice cream has 125 calories
seven grams of fat and 14 grams of sugar
the main ingredients are heavy cream and
egg yolks shopping for gelato instead
gelato uses more milk than cream and
fewer egg yolks a similar portion packs
in just 90 calories 3 grams of fat and
pang grams of sugar remember to still
indulge in moderation red meat is an
excellent source of protein and iron but
can be high in saturated fats consuming
too much of red meat can cause high
cholesterol and also cardiovascular
diseases limit red meat to once a week
and swap it for fish instead fish is
high in protein omega-3 but low in
calories and saturated fats desserts
tend to be very high in calories at a
400 calories per slice of cheesecake it
can contain more calories than your
dinner swap it for jell-o pudding
instead one serving has 150 calories
you'll be saving 250 calories plus your
efforts in the gym all these little food
swaps can add up to some huge calorie
savings start by practicing these really
simple food swaps and you will notice a
difference to your body and also how you
feel what other food swaps have you
tried to let me know in the comments
below so if you enjoyed this video if
you find this video to be helpful be
sure to give it a thumbs up share it
with your friends and do subscribe to my
youtube channel for new weekly videos do
also check out more video links in my
description box for more guides and tips
on healthy eating all the best
[Music]
you